MEMBERS HERE. OF WE HAVE ONE
ITEM TODAY ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THAT AJ ARE SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THREE OF US. AND
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME WILL
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR TO
MEASURES TODAY THESE MEASURES
ARE WILL BE HEARD IN FILE ORDER
AND I WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE
THAT THE WAY WE WORK HERE IS
THERE WE- INVITE THE AUTHOR TO
DO THE PRESENTATION TO
WITNESSES ON EACH SIDE. TWO
MINUTES EACH AFTER WE HEAR THE
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT WE WILL
THEN OPEN THE MICROPHONE IN THE
BACK HERE FOR PEOPLE TO STEP
FORWARD AND TO. INDICATE THEIR
SUPPORT BY GIVING US THEIR NAME
AND THEIR AFFILIATION THEN WE
WILL BRING THE OPPOSITION IN
TWO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH
AND AGAIN GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF PEOPLE COMING UP TO
THE MICROPHONE. TO INDICATE
THEIR NAME. THEIR AFFILIATION
AND OF COURSE THEIR OPPOSITION
THERE'S ALSO PLACE FOR THOSE
WHO ARE STRONGLY NEUTRAL TO
COME IN AND TO GIVE US. THEIR
STATEMENT AGAIN THAT JUST
INDICATING THEIR NEUTRALITY ON
THE BILL SO WITH THAT WE WILL
START WITH FILE ITEM ONE WHICH
IS ACR NINETY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW. GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT IT TO YOU ACR NINETY
NINE WHICH IS. A RESOLUTION.
WITH RESPECT TO CONVERSION
THERAPY AS MANY OF YOU MAY
RECALL IN PREVIOUS YEARS OF
INTRODUCTIONS OF A NUMBER OF.
FORMATIVE LE LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS TO ENSURE THAT WE
PROTECT ALL PEOPLE INCLUDING
MEMBERS OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY
WITH RESPECT TO THEIR IDENTITY
AND WHO THEY ARE AS IT
INDIVIDUALS LAST YEAR WE HAD
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE FORTY
THREE. IN WHICH WE HAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT INCLUDING
FOR MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
AT TO ENSURE THAT WE QUALIFIED.
CONVERSION THERAPY HAS
FRAUDULENT PRACTICE A PART OF
THAT CONVERSATION WAS SUCH THAT
WE ALSO. WERE ABLE TO MEET A
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS IN THE
COMMUNITY THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
STATE PARTICULARLY EVANGELICALS
WHO WOULD JOIN IN HANDS WITH
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY STATE
THAT HOW WE DO NOT BELIEVE IN
CONVERSION THERAPY WE ALSO
CONDEMN IT EQUALLY AS WELL. WE
PUT A PAUSE ON THAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR BELIEVE
THAT WE WOULD HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BACK THIS
YEAR WITH THE RESOLUTION
JOINING HANDS. WITH THOSE IN
THE EVANGELICAL COMMUNITY TO
ALSO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF WHO WE
ARE AS A COMMUNITY AND HAS
INDIVIDUALS WITH THIS RESPECT
TO. QUALIFYING CONVERSION
THERAPY AS A HARMFUL PRACTICE
AND SO BEFORE YOU YOU HAVE. A
RESOLUTION THAT ENJOYS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH
EVANGELICAL. LEADERS THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE STATE TO ALSO TALK
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
RECOGNIZING THE LGBT COMMUNITY
AS- A COMMUNITY MEMBER AS TO
THE ARE. OUT WITHOUT
SACRIFICING THEIR INTEGRITY OR
CONVICTION AND WITH RESPECT
WELL THROUGHOUT THE VOTE AND
SUPPORT. BUT WE HAVE UP
INDIVIDUALS SO IN SUPPORT AS
WELL THANK YOU AND I DO RECALL
WE HAD. RATHER. ROBUST HEARING
LAST TIME WHEN THIS WAS A AB.
TWENTY FORTY THREE FORTY THREE
SO I THINK SOME OF US HERE WHO
WERE YEAH LOOK AROUND I THINK
I'M THE ONLY ONE WHO REMEMBERS
THAT HEARING. BUT CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE YOU BRING THIS
BACK. TODAY IN THE FORM OF
RESOLUTION. TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH YOU GO AHEAD AND-
CHOOSE WHO YOU WANT TO BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RICK
SERVER AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF A QUALITY
CALIFORNIA WHICH FOR TWENTY
YEARS HAS LED THE GOLDEN
STATE'S FIGHT FOR FULL. LIVED
LGBT Q. A QUALITY. I'M HERE
TODAY AND RECOGNITION OF THE
SURVIVORS OF SO CALLED
CONVERSION THERAPY A DANGEROUS
AND DECEPTIVE PRACTICE WITH NO
SCIENTIFIC BASIS WHICH CAN
CAUSE LIFELONG DAMAGE. I'M ALSO
HERE WITH IMMENSE GRATITUDE FOR
THE MANY HOURS OF COLLABORATION
THAT WENT INTO THIS RESOLUTION.
COLLABORATION BETWEEN AND AMONG
LGBT Q. LEADERS INCLUDING LGBT
Q. PEOPLE OF FAITH FAITH
LEADERS AND THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED ADVERSELY BY
CONVERSION THERAPY. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE A QUALITY
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSORED THE
BILL THAT ULTIMATELY PROHIBITED
LICENSED MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS FROM PERFORMING SO
CALLED CONVERSION THERAPY ON
YOUNG ADULTS ARE. PEOPLE UNDER
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN. SINCE THEN
EIGHTEEN OTHER STATES HAVE
ENACTED SIMILAR LAWS
DEMONSTRATING A GROWING
NATIONAL CONSENSUS THAT THESE
PRACTICES ARE DANGEROUS AND
DAMAGING. UNFORTUNATELY THESE
PRACTICES ARE STILL CARRIED OUT
BY PEOPLE WHO ARE ENTRUSTED TO
CARE FOR THE EMOTIONAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL WELL BEING OF
OTHERS. ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
STILL RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
LGBT Q. PEOPLE ATTEMPT SUICIDE
MORE OFTEN EXPERIENCE
DEPRESSION MORE OFTEN AND
EXPERIENCE HOMELESS THIS MORE
OFTEN THAN PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
LGBT Q. WHY IT'S BECAUSE LGBT
Q. PEOPLE ARE TOO OFTEN TOLD
THAT THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG
WITH THEM AND US. AND THE
PRACTICE OF CONVERSION THERAPY
SENDS THAT MESSAGE. LOUD AND
CLEAR AND RESULTS IN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ABUSE AND DAMAGE
THAT CAN CAUGHT LITERALLY COST
LIVES. LET ME BE CLEAR THERE'S
NOTHING WRONG WITH ME THERE'S
NOTHING WRONG WITH LGBT Q.
PEOPLE AND THE NATION'S LEADING
PROFESSIONAL MEDICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH ASSOCIATIONS THE
AMERICAN PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION. THE AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL SAYS
COUNSELING CESSATION NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS.
AND AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION HAVE REJECTED
CONVERSION. B. AS UNNECESSARY
INEFFECTIVE AND HARMFUL AND
TODAY WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
YOU DO THE SAME THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TIM
RAMEL AND I'M A CONVERSION
THERAPY SURVIVOR AND AUTHOR.
AND I'M SURE YOU'VE HEARD OF
THE STORIES LIKE MINE IS A
CONVERSION THERAPY SURVIVOR BUT
WHAT MAKES MY DIFFERENT AS I
WAS ALSO CONVERSION THERAPY
LEADER. I ATTEMPTED SUICIDE
BEFORE GOING INTO CONVERSION
THERAPY BECAUSE THAT WAS MY
LAST HOPE. AND SO I NEEDED
SOMETHING THAT WAS GOING TO
RECONCILE MY FAITH WITH MY
REALITY. AND DURING THE TIME
THAT I WAS THERE I TRULY
BELIEVE THAT GOD HAD CHANGE ME.
AND IN FACT I BELIEVE THAT SO
MUCH THAT AFTER I WENT THROUGH
CONVERSION THERAPY I WENT ON
STAFF WITH THIS ORGANIZATION
AND IT WORKED FOR THEM FOR FIVE
YEARS. DURING THAT TIME I GOT
MARRIED EVENTUALLY HAD TWO
BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTERS. AND I
TRAVEL THE NATION PREACHING
THIS MESSAGE THAT I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS FREEDOM FROM
HOMOSEXUALITY THROUGH JESUS
CHRIST. TEN YEARS AFTER I LEFT
THE MINISTRY. OFF THE STAGE AND
AWAY FROM THE SPOTLIGHT.
REALITY SET IN FOR ME AND MY
LIFE CAME CRASHING DOWN. AND I
THOUGHT THERE WAS SOMETHING SO
DEEPLY FLAWED WITHIN ME THAT I
WAS AND REDEEMABLE AN
UNREACHABLE. THAN AND LOVABLE.
I HAVE TO SAY IT'S BEEN NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE YEARS SINCE I WAS
INVOLVED IN CONVERSION THERAPY.
BUT JUST BECAUSE YOU OF THE
PASTORS OFFICER YOU CLOSE THE
THERAPISTS DOOR. DOESN'T MEAN
THOSE MESSAGES GO AWAY. THEY
DON'T. I'VE BEEN FORTUNATE TO
BE WITH THE MAN IS NOW MY
HUSBAND FOR NEARLY TEN YEARS
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT MANY OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'VE HAD IN
OUR RELATIONSHIP STEM FROM
THOSE MESSAGES THAT I HEARD
OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN MY
EVANGELICAL UPBRINGING. AND IN
THE CONVERSION THERAPY
MOVEMENT. AND AT TIMES IT
ALMOST DESTROYED US. CONVERSION
THERAPY IS DISRUPTIVE. IT'S
DESTRUCTIVE. AND THE EFFECTS OF
THAT ARE FELT IN PEOPLE
SOMETIMES MANY MANY YEARS AFTER
THEY LEAVE IT AFFECTS FAMILIES
AND IT AFFECTS INDIVIDUALS.
WHAT I WISH SOMEONE HAD TOLD ME
THIRTY YEARS AGO. WAS THAT I
COULD HAVE LIVE A LIFE OF FAITH
I COULD HAVE A LOVING HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIP WITH SOMEBODY OF
THE SAME SEX. I WISH SOMEBODY
HAD TOLD ME YOU'RE LOVABLE NO
MATTER WHAT. AND YOUR
ACCEPTABLE AND YOUR VALUABLE
AND YOUR VOICE NEEDS TO BE
HEARD. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH UP WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND THE STYLISH
THAT QUORUM WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MA'AM SIX.
JACKSON JACKSON HERE PORGES.
FORGES HERE DO RUSSELL. RUSSELL
HERE GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ HERE
JONES. JONES HERE MONNING.
MONNING HERE STERN. A BURKE
OVER HERE WE CASKEY. ALL RIGHT
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WHEN WE GO
AHEAD WE HAD ONE ITEM ON
CONSENT WHY DON'T WE TAKE CARE
OF THAT RIGHT NOW IT IS FILE
ITEM TO AJ ARE SIXTEEN. OF THIS
PROMOTION. MOST MOVED BY
SENATOR RUSSELL OF PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. EIGHTY ARE SIXTEEN.
YES AGE A R. SIXTEEN ON SIXTEEN
BY THE ONE CONSENT DIDYMUS YES
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE PORCHES
GORGEOUS I'D TO RUSSELL RUSSELL
I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I'D JONES
JONES I AM MONNING. MONNING AYE
STERN. NUMBER NUMBER OF IOWA
CASKEY. BUSINESSES WITH
UNIFORMS. ALL RIGHT THE. OKAY
IS SEVEN THIS YEAR WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN MY APOLOGIES JUST
WANTED TO GET THAT OUT OF THE
WAY PEOPLE TEND TO COME IN AND
I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GET
EVERYTHING CORRECT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION IF YOU WOULD
STEP FOR WITH YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION ONLY PLEASE AS THE
CENTER OF AB RECORDS ADVOCATES
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
JACKIE STERN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BREAKER YOSHIHARA BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PLAN MILLERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MATTHEW NIELSEN STONE WALL
DEMOCRATIC CLUB OF GREATER
SACRAMENTO STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU. I HAD A CONTEST LGBT
Q. COMMITTEE MEMBER AND ON OUR
BEHALF THE GENDER HEALTH CENTER
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KEEP A TAURUS LGBT Q. I A
COMMUNITY MEMBER AND THE
GENERAL TENOR IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEIL NGUYEN TRANS
WOMAN OF COLOR ALLIANCE FOR
TRANS RIGHTS STILL HERE AND
PART OF THE GENDER HEALTH
CENTER I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'LL TURN
DAY COOK TO STRONG SUPPORTER
PART OF AGENDA HOUSE CENTER AND
ALSO NINE NINE A COMMUNITY
MEMBER. THANK YOU. REBEKAH
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. TAMMY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS ON BEHALF OF VOICES
FOR PROGRESS WHO ARE NOT ABLE
TO BE HERE TODAY. AND WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. CHECK
OF RECORD LGBT Q. COMMUNITY
MEMBER AND THE UC BERKELEY
SOCIAL WELFARE DEPARTMENT AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON BEHALF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AMANDA
LEVY WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ROD BRAZENLY
SENIOR PASTOR FIRST UNITED
METHODIST CHURCH RIGHT DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. DARIA GREW STONE
WALL FOUNDATION OF GREATER
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ILEANA COMPARE LE
CLAIR WITHDREW. NORTH AND ARE
CAL RESIST STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MEGAN ALL RIGHT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. STEPHEN SALLY WITH THE
SACRAMENTO O. G. B. T.
COMMUNITY CENTER COMPLETELY
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ABLE PRESS
CONVERSION THERE BE SURVIVORS
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU. I
SHEPHERD ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION FOR
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPISTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT THE THOSE IN OPPOSITION
IF YOU'D LIKE TO STEP FORWARD.
TWO WITNESSES PLEASE TWO
MINUTES EACH. GOOD AFTERNOON
YOU MAY PROCEED GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M DEAN BROYLES AN ATTORNEY
WITH THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
LONG POLICY YOU HAVE MY
OPPOSITION LETTER. GOVERNMENT
HAS NO JURISDICTION TO DICTATE
TO THE CHURCH WHAT IT SHOULD
BELIEVE DO SAY OR HOW IT
COUNSEL CITIZENS. WHY WHY IS
THAT TRUE. THE FIRST AMENDMENT
EMBEDDED IN THE CONSTITUTION'S
BILL OF RIGHTS GUARANTEES OUR
UNALIENABLE AND FUNDAMENTAL
CIVIL RIGHTS INCLUDING THE FREE
EXERCISE OF RELIGION AND THE
FREEDOM OF SPEECH. ACR NINETY
NINE IS AN ATTEMPT TO CONTROL
THE BELIEVES WORDS AND
PRACTICES OF CITIZENS REGARDING
THE CONTROVERSIAL AND SENSITIVE
TOPIC OF HUMAN SEXUALITY. IT
TARGETS CHILLS AND SUPPRESSES
FREE SPEECH AND RELIGIOUS FREE
EXERCISE FURTHERMORE IT
UNFAIRLY DISPARAGES RELIGIOUS
GROUPS AND PEOPLE BLAMING THEM
FOR MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS AND
HIGH SUICIDE RATE IN THE LGBT
COMMUNITY. THE RIGHT TO DISSENT
IS A FUNDAMENTAL AMERICAN RIGHT
ROBUSTLY PROTECTED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. THE STATE DOES NOT
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DEFINE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL SEXUAL
IDEOLOGY OR TO ENFORCE ITS
CENTRAL ORTHODOXY ON PEOPLE OF
FAITH. SEXUAL ORIENTATION
GENDER IDENTITY ARE NOT FIX
THEIR FLUID. PEOPLE CAN CHANGE
PEOPLE DO CHANGE OUR CITIZENS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO HAVE FAITH
SHOULD REMAIN FREE TO HAVE THE
CHOICE TO SEEK OUT CHANGE
ALLOWING THERAPY WITHOUT THE
STATE TRYING TO DESTROY THE
CHOICE TO OR WELL IN
LEGISLATION LIKE AB TWENTY NINE
FORTY THREE AND ACR NINETY
NINE. GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
PONDERING THIS RESOLUTION TO BE
MINDFUL TO SUPPORT COURT CASES
AND RULINGS LAST YEAR IN
MASTERPIECE CAKE SHOP THE
COLORADO STATE COLORADO FOUND
WAS FOUND HIM UNFAIRLY TARGETED
JACK PHILLIPS CHRISTIAN
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS ABOUT
MARRIAGE HOLDING THAT EVEN
SUBTLE DEPARTURES FROM
RELIGIOUS GOVERNMENT RELIGIOUS
NEUTRALITY VIOLATE THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. FOR THE MORE IN
DEPTH OF RESERVISTS SURE THE
COURT OVERTURNED CALIFORNIA'S
AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WHY BECAUSE
IT UNFAIRLY TARGETED PREGNANCY
CARE CENTERS AND
UNCONSTITUTIONALLY COMPELLED
GOVERNMENT SANCTIONED SPEECH
ACR NINETY NINE IS RELIGIOUSLY
INTOLERANT IT'S NOT INCLUSIVE
OF PEOPLE OF FAITH AND IS A
DANGEROUS STEP TOWARD THE
DESTRUCTION OF DIVERSITY IN
CALIFORNIA. PEOPLE FACE SHOULD
NOT BE MADE TO FEEL LIKE ON
WELCOME OUTSIDERS IN THE STATE
THANK YOU WRONGLY RIVER URGE
YOU TO VOTE AGAINST THIS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS BUT GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM PHYLLIS TOLLS
REPRESENTING DR SAM YOUR
RODRIGUEZ WITH. NATIONAL
HISPANIC CHRISTIAN. SHIP
CONFERENCE WHERE WE HAVE FORTY
TWO THOUSAND PLUS CHARGES. I
SIT BEFORE YOU AS A FRIEND AND
CONFIDENT TO THOSE WHO HAVE
SOUGHT AND RECEIVED
PROFESSIONAL BIBLICAL BASED
COUNSELING FROM CHRISTIANS. WHO
SEE THE IMAGE OF GOD IN EVERY
HUMAN BEING REGARDLESS OF
SEXUAL ORIENTATION. TO PROTECT
THE FREEDOM OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO SEEK SUCH
GUIDANCE. TO CHAMPION THE RIGHT
TO BE LIGHT BY RECONCILING
RIGHTEOUSNESS WITH JUSTICE.
THANK THE VACATION WITH SERVICE
HOLINESS WITH HUMILITY AND
TRUTH WITH LOVE. TO ENGAGE IN
POWER AND IN RICH EVERY HUMAN
LIFE THROUGH THE TRANSFORMATIVE
POWER OF GOD'S WORD. TO
ADVOCATE AN INDIVIDUAL'S
FREEDOM TO CHOOSE QUESTION AND
CHANGE. ACR NINETY NINE WOULD
PROHIBIT THE SAME INDIVIDUALS
THEIR FREEDOM. TO SEEK
PROFESSIONAL HELP THROUGH
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE SAFE
LEGAL THERAPEUTIC SERVICES.
JESUS CHRIST DIED AND ROSE
AGAIN SO THAT EVERY HUMAN BEING
CREATED IN THE IMAGE OF GOD
COULD HAVE THE FREEDOM TO NOT
BE CONTROLLED BY THEIR PHYSICAL
OR SEXUAL DESIRES BUT RATHER
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT TO CHANGE.
NOT ONLY IN THEIR SEXUALITY BUT
ALL ASPECTS OF THEIR LIFE. AS A
PROBLEM MOTHER AND GRANDMOTHER
IF THESE WERE MY GRANDCHILDREN
I WOULD WANT THEM TO BE FREE TO
SEEK COUNSELING FROM
ORGANIZATIONS AND RELIGIOUS
LEADERS IN LINE WITH THEIR
PERSONAL VALUES. THE STATE DOES
NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO READ JUST
LET LEGISLATOR FEB DETER DEEPLY
PERSONAL MATTERS ON BEHALF OF
THE FORTY TWO THOUSAND PLUS
CHURCHES MY GRANDCHILDREN AND
YOURS RESCUE TO VOTE NO WHEN
ACR NINETY NINE OR ABSTAINED.
THANK YOU. MUCH OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO A STEP FORWARD. GIVE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION ONLY
PLEASE. THING IN THE RIVER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. BOB
DORNAN PASTOR THE DINNER
MISSIONARY BAPTIST CHURCH
OPPOSES HEARING ON. MICHAEL
MANZI CHAIRMAN OF FOR HIS NEW
CREATION MINISTRY STRONGLY
OPPOSE BECAUSE I'VE SEEN THE
HEALING POWER JESUS MANY OF
THESE THANK YOU CHARLES THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS DAVID FISHER
REPRESENTING CENTRAL PENINSULAS
CHURCH PARENT FAMILY SUPPORT
GROUP IN FOSTER CITY. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE ACR NINETY NINE
THANK YOU. BETTY STALIN'S A
PRIVATE CITIZEN MOTHER
GRANDMOTHER AND EVANGELICAL
CHRISTIAN. THANK YOU. I'M JIM
STALIN'S ALSO A PRIVATE CITIZEN
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT GOVERNMENT
OVER STEP A GREAT FATHER
GRANDFATHER AND HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO THIS RANK YOU. ELIZABETH
WANTING CO FOUNDER OF CHANGED
OPPOSING THIS RESOLUTION THANK
YOU. CARMEN VOTE ON BEHALF OF
CHANGED IN A PERSONAL STORY OF
CHANGE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. CHRIS FOR SENSE AND
ON BEHALF OF CHANGED IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. STEPHEN
ROADS THAT LEAD PASTOR
GENERATION LIFE CHURCH SUTTER
CREEK CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. ZACK FISHER
ASSEMBLY IS ASSN WAS GOD
GENERATION AFTER TO STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. ROSY FISHER
MINISTER TO CHILDREN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. DAVID REES ON
BEHALF OF THE CHANGE MOVEMENT
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU. PLAN
RAISE MY MARRIAGE EXIST BECAUSE
OF CHANGE I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. IN A CRAFTSMAN WAS
CHANGE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. HE MILLION WITH
CHANGE MOVEMENT I OPPOSE THIS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU. CALEB
BARGAIN WITH CHANGE I OPPOSE
THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU. THAT
INDICATES WITH CHANGE MOVEMENT
AND I OPPOSE THANK YOU. JESUS
BUT OUR ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR SALEM
MEDIA GROUP WE OPPOSE THIS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS SARAH JULIA HARRINGTON. I AM
THE GRANDMOTHER OF TWENTY FIVE
GREAT AND GREAT GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. IN SACRAMENTO
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT ARE
TEACHING THEM THEIR GENDER IS
FLUID THANK YOU EVERY ONE OF
YOUR YOUR EXCUSE MOTOR IN YOUR
JEWS MAKE UNDER THE PLEA EXCUSE
ME MA'AM YOU HAVE IN YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION AND THAT'S ALL
WE ASK FOR AT THIS POINT TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. EIGHT
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. APPEARS AND MEMBER OF THE
COLLISION COALITION FOR
COUNSELING CHOICE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. GAIL HARRISON
PRIVATE COUNSELOR I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. HAVE A NON
OCCURS I AM A RETIRED RN AND
MOM AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THOSE
THAT HAVE BEEN. THANK YOU. USE
THANK YOU. RANDOLPH CHANGED I
STRONGLY OPPOSES CRITICS HAVE
BEEN PRIDE UNITY IN SAN
FRANCISCO THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
LISA JENKS I'M FROM NEW LIFE
CHURCH IN SAN DIEGO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. HELLO KELLY ROBBINS
I'M A MOTHER AND GRANDMOTHER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE THANK
YOU. I'M TRYING TO KILLINGS AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU SIR. SENATORS THANK
YOU MY NAME IS JONATHAN KELLER
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL I FIRST OFF ON A STATE
ASSEMBLYMAN LOW THANK YOU FOR
YOUR OUT REACH TO THE FAITH
COMMUNITY. WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS HE'S
MADE TO HEAR OUR CONCERNS
RESPECTFULLY WE STILL MUST
OPPOSE THE BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DíAS
SENATOR UMBERG YOU HAD A
QUESTION. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THAT QUESTION THE OPPOSITION I
LISTEN YOUR TESTIMONY AND SO
THEN I ACTUALLY READ THE
RESOLUTION. AND I'M WONDERING
WHAT PARTS OF THE RESOLUTION
SPECIFICALLY ARE YOU OPPOSED
TO. AS I READ THE PORTIONS THAT
SAID THAT THE LEGISLATURE CALLS
UPON RELIGIOUS LEADERS. DID
COUNSEL. LGBT Q. MATTERS
REPLACE OF LOVE AND COMPASSION
IS THAT. ARE YOU OPPOSE THAT
PART. ARE YOU OPPOSED I'M SORRY
GO AHEAD YOU ARE NO WE'RE NOT
AT ALL OF ALL TO LIVE IN
COMPASSION. OKAY WHAT WHAT PART
SPECIFICALLY ARE YOU OPPOSED TO.
ON. I AM AGAINST THE PART THAT
THE BLAMES FAITH COMMUNITIES
FOR THE STIGMA AND HIGH SUICIDE
RATES IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS I THINK THE SOCIAL
SCIENCE DOESN'T SUPPORT THAT AS
A MATTER OF FACT IT'S THE
OPPOSITE I'M AGAINST THE PARTS
OF THE BILL THE CALL ON A
RELIGIOUS LEADERS AND PASTORS
AND CHURCHES SPECIFICALLY TO
TAKEN AFFIRMING POSITION ON
LGBT ISSUES WHEN OUR FAITH
COUNSELS US IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION SO WE'RE NOT AGAINST
LOVE WERE NOT AGAINST
COMPASSION. WE JUST HAVE A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ON SEXUAL
ISSUES AND SO IT'S NOT THE JOB
OF THE STATE TO TELL THE CHURCH
WHAT TO BELIEVE OR HOW TO
COUNSEL I DON'T SEE THAT IN THE
RESOLUTE WHAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED AS SIMPLY DON'T SEE
THAT IN THE RESOLUTION THAT'S
WHY I WAS ASKING ABOUT SPECIFIC
PORTIONS THAT YOU DISAGREED
WITH SO FOR EXAMPLE IT CALLS
UPON RELIGIOUS LEADERS TO MODEL
EQUITABLE TREATMENT OF ALL
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OR- THAT
WHEN YOU'RE OPPOSED TO DO NOT
NOT AT ALL. AS A MATTER OF FACT
WE'RE FOR LOVE WERE FOR
COMPASSION WERE FOR EQUITABLE
TREATMENT. WE JUST BELIEVE THAT
THE STATE. THIS IS THE FIRST
BILL THAT I'VE EVER SEEN IN MY
TWENTY FIVE YEARS INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA. WHERE SPECIFICALLY
EVEN THOUGH TO RESOLUTION IT
DOESN'T HAVE BINDING AFFECTING
TEETH. IT CALLS OUT CHURCHES
AND RELIGIOUS LEADERS TO TAKE A
SPECIFIC. PERSPECTIVE ON
MORALITY AND SEXUALITY HUMAN
SEXUALITY AND THAT IS NOT THE
JOB OF THE STATE AND SO AS A
RESOLUTION OF THE STATE. EVEN
BILLS THAT DON'T HAVE TEETH
BILLS THAT CHILL RELIGIOUS FREE
EXERCISE OR BILLS THAT CHILL
RELIGIOUS SPEECH. ARE ALSO
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. THE COURT
SAID LAST YEAR IN THE CASES OUT
OF COLORADO I CITED EARLIER.
THE EVEN SUBTLE DEPARTURES FROM
NEUTRALITY OF THE STATE TOWARDS
RELIGIOUS GROUPS. IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL THIS IS MORE
THAN JUST SUBTLE. LACK OF
NEUTRALITY TOWARDS RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS AND PRACTICES IT'S
SPECIFICALLY TELLING US WHAT TO
BELIEVE HOW TO PREACH AND HOW
TO COUNSEL AND THAT'S BLATANTLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. THANK YOU
JUST BUILD ON WHAT MY WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE IS SAYING WITH
RESPECT TO THE GENTLEMEN I
THINK HERE. IT WOULD LIMIT
OTHER PEOPLE'S FREEDOM TO BE
ABLE TO THINK THAT FAME COUNCIL
WE BELIEVE IN THE RIGHT FOR
CHOICE. SO IF I AM OR IF MY
GRANDCHILDREN I USE THAT AGAIN
AS AN EXAMPLE A PROBLEM MOTHER
OF TWO AND TWO GRANDCHILDREN.
IF THEY WERE IN THE LGBT
COMMUNITY I WOULD WANT THEM TO
HAVE THE FREEDOM TO SEEK
RELIGIOUS COUNCIL THAT ALIGNS
WITH THEIR VALUES AND BELIEF
SYSTEM. AND THIS WOULD TAKE
THAT AWAY FROM THEM WE'RE NOT
SAYING THERE WERE OPPOSED TO
ANYONE THAT WE DON'T LOVE OF
COURSE WE DO BUT WE ALSO WANT
THE RIGHT. FOR THOSE WHO SAY I
DESIRE CHANGE OR AT LEAST TO
QUESTION IT AND TO SEEK THE
COUNSEL ALLOWED WITH OUR.
VALUES BASED UPON THE BIBLE THE
RIGHT TO DO THAT. ADAM CHAIR
ALL OF US HERE. OF COME TO THIS
JOB WITH THE- EXPERIENCES OF
OUR OWN AND WE ALL APPLY THOSE
EXPERIENCES TO OUR PERSPECTIVE.
AND I THINK ALL OF US BELIEVE
THAT THE STATE HAS A DUTY TO
PROTECT CERTAIN CITIZENS AND I
COME HERE WITH THE PERSPECTIVE.
FROM WATCHING MY BROTHER IN LAW
GOES THROUGH CONVERSION THERAPY
AND THE HARM THAT IT DID TO
HIM. INTO ITS ENTIRE HIS ENTIRE
FAMILY. SO I BELIEVE THE STATE
DOES HAVE A VERY STRONG
INTEREST IN PREVENTING THAT
KIND OF HARM IN HAVING
WITNESSED IT MYSELF I I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND I COMMEND
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER. LOW FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS THANK
YOU EXCUSE ME THERE'S NO
QUESTION EXCUSE WAS NO QUESTION
PENDING. THANK THANK YOU CENTER
NUMBER CENTER JONES YOU HAVE A
QUESTION. MADAM CHAIR AND I'M
AT I THINK A SINNER AMBERG FOR
ACTUALLY BRINGING UP THAT EXACT
PARAGRAPH BECAUSE IT WAS A-
KIND THE PARAGRAPH THAT ICE
SIGNALLED SINGLED OUT AS- AS
HAVING SOME CHALLENGES WITHAND
THE- THE PARAGRAPH DOES. SAVE A
PLACE OF LOVE AND COMPASSION.
WHICH IN MY EXPERIENCE AS A
FORMER PASTOR. MOST MOST OF THE
FOLKS THAT I KNOW IN THAT
PROFESSION TO COME FROM THAT
ANGLE OF LOVE AND COMPASSION
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE-
EVENTUAL OUTCOME OF THE OF THE
COUNSELING IS. BUT WHERE THE
PARAGRAPH GOES TOO FAR IF YOU.
KEPT QUOTING ON THERE IS. IT'S
THE STATE THROUGH THE AC ARE
REQUIRING THOSE COUNSELORS. IN
A PLACE OF LOVE AND COMPASSION
TO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL ANOTHER HARMS OF
CONVERSION THERAPY. WELL THAT'S
THE DEBATE AND I THINK THAT.
THAT THAT'S THE IF I'M
UNDERSTANDING THE OPPONENTS
PROPERLY AND CORRECTLY. THAT'S
THE PART OF ACR THAT THE
BIGGEST PART ACR THAT GOES TOO
FAR IS THE STATE COMPELLING
THEM TO ACKNOWLEDGE. COME FROM
A BACKGROUND AND LIFE
EXPERIENCE OF SEEING POSITIVE
RESULTS OF THAT CONVERSION
THERAPY SO I JUST WANTED TO BUT
ON THE WRECK I'M HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS LATER BUT IS ONE TO
ADDRESS THAT SINCE IT WAS. I
THANK YOU SENATOR PORCHES
FOLLOWED BY A SENATOR GONZALEZ
AND THEN SENATOR RUSSELL.
FIGURE CHAIRWOMAN. I THINK THE
FACT THIS IS A RESOLUTION AS
OPPOSED TO. A SUBSTANTIVE PIECE
OF LEGISLATION SPEAKS VOLUMES
BUT UNFORTUNATE THINK WHEN WE
HAVE HIGHLY CONTROVERSIAL
TOPICS YOU KNOW EVEN SYMBOLIC.
ON DISCUSSIONS TAKE ON GRAVITY.
I KIND OF WANT TO JUST TO
REAFFIRM THE FRAMEWORK THAT
WERE. SEEING THIS ISSUE WITH.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A PRIVATE
SETTING IN A CHURCH OR A
MINISTER IS THAT CORRECT IT'S
NOT A PUBLIC SETTING RIGHT. AND
IS IT VOLUNTARY. AND IT IS A
CONFIDENTIAL YES IS IT ARE YOU
AWARE OF MINISTRIES CAM
CONDITIONING THEIR MEMBERSHIP
OF THAT INDIVIDUAL ON THE TO
THIS COUNSELING ANDULTIMATELY
THROUGH A CONVERSION THERAPY
PROCESS DISHING THEM YEAH
MEANING THAT THEY WOULD LOSE
THEIR MEMBERSHIP IN THE MOSQUE
THE TEMPLE THE CHURCH. ALL
RIGHT I HAPPEN TO HAVE BEEN
REARED GREEK ORTHODOX FAIRLY
CONSERVATIVE CHRISTIAN ON GREEK
ORTHODOX. I HAPPENTO HAVE A
LOT OF FOLKS ON YOUR FRIENDS IN
THE LGBT. COMMUNITY I HAVE
RECONCILED ABSOLUTELY MY FAITH
WITH MY ABILITY TO EXPRESS MY
LOVE AND COMPASSION. TO MY
FRIENDS IN THOSE OUTSIDE OF MY
FAITH AND I KNOW FOLKS WHO
ALSO. MAYBE HOMOSEXUAL OR
WITHIN THIS COMMUNITY WHO ARE
ALSO MEMBERS OF THE CHURCH SO
THERE'S A RECONCILIATION IT MAY
BE THAT WORKS FOR SOME MAYBE
NOT FOR EVERYONE BUT THE ISSUE
HERE AT LEAST IN MY OPINION. IS
THAT. WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE IS A FREEDOM OF
RELIGION AND THEN THERE'S A
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION. AND SO
FROM A LEGAL STANDPOINT. WELL I
HAVEN'T WEIGHED IN ON
CONVERSION THERAPY AND FRANKLY
DON'T KNOW TOO MUCH ABOUT IT I
MUST CONFESS MAYBE IT IS STRICT
MAYBE IT IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
AYE I'M NOT IN THE FIELD OF
THAT AREA OF STUDY. BUT JUST
REMAIN FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION
AND FREEDOM OF RELIGION
STANDPOINT I DON'T KNOW HOW WE
WOULD WANT TO ON DO THE
PROTECTIONS THAT. OUR
CONSTITUTION ALLOWS OF FOR
THOSE IN THE FAITH COMMUNITY.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT EVERYTHING
THAT YOU JUST SAID IS VOLUNTARY
CONFIDENTIAL AND ARE NOT
CONDITION YOUR MEMBERSHIP IN
THAT RELIGIOUS INSTITUTION.
RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR GONZALEZ. YOU AND I AM
I'M ALWAYS GRAPPLING JUST
PERSONALLY BECAUSE THIS IS A
VERY DIFFICULT OUR TOPIC FOR
MANY OF THE RESIDENTS THAT I
REPRESENT WHO ARE AT LONG BEACH
RESIDENTS MANY OF WHICH TO DO
IDENTIFIES LGBT Q. WHO HAVE
GONE THROUGH CONVERSION THERAPY
AND HAVE SEEN VERY POOR POOR
AND DETRIMENTAL RESULTS AND SO
I COME FROM THAT LENDS FIRST
AND FOREMOST AS A
REPRESENTATIVE THAT HAS OF A
MULTITUDE OF NOT ONLY FRIENDS
BUT- PEOPLE THAT I REPRESENT.
SO I THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND FOR YOUR EYES SUPPORTERS
FOR BRINGING THIS FORD ENSURING
THEIR STORY AS WELL AS THE
OPPONENTS FOR GIVING US A
GLIMPSE AS TO WHAT THE COUNTER
ARGUMENTS ARE BUT I JUST WANT
TO BE LABOR ONE SPECIFIC UP
RIGHT HERE IN THE RESOLUTION
ALSO CALLED OUT BY SENATOR
UMBERG BUT CALIFORNIA LAW
ALREADY RECOGNIZES THAT
PERFORMING THIS TYPE OF
CONVERSION THERAPY. ON YOUNG
PERSONS IS INEFFECTIVE AN
ETHICAL AND HARMFUL SO THIS IN
ISN'T OUT OF OUR WHEEL HOUSE TO
BE ADDING THIS ADDITIONAL
RESOLUTION THAT WOULD INCLUDE
YOU KNOW THIS ALL OF THE ITEMS
THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED HERE TODAY
WELL JUST A BELIEVER THAT POINT
THAT WE ALREADY RECOGNIZING
THIS UP FIRST AND SECONDLY AS
YOU READ THE ANALYSIS. ISN'T SO
MUCH AN ISSUE OF FREEDOM OF
SPEECH AS IT IS ON ON
PROFESSIONAL CON. AS RIGHT HERE
IN THE- IN THE RESPONSE TO THIS
TYPE OF THERAPY OVERALL. SO
WE'RE NOT. IMPEDING ON ANY OF
THAT WHATSOEVER AND FUNDS FREE
SPEECH AS WE ARE AN
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT SO I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT AND I WOULD
JUST SAY. I HOPE. OVERALL THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO CONTINUE.
THESE DISCUSSIONS AND THAT WE
CAN FORMALLY HAVE A CONVERSION
THERAPY IN MY OPINION
COMPLETELY OUT OF OUR- WE'LL
HOUSE THAT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
IS WHAT WE BELIEVE AND I
BELIEVE THERE REALLY.
CALIFORNIA VALUES SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR
DOOR ALSO FOLLOW BY STATE OR
MONNING. THERE'S TWO ISSUES ONE
IS OF MAKING SURE THAT WE
PROTECT OF THE FREEDOM. OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. TO BE TREATED
WITH THE RESPECT AND NOT TO
FEEL THAT THEY ARE ISOLATED
THAT THEY ARE IN DANGER.
PARTICULARLY ARE MINORS I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF PROTECTIONS
THAT WE HAVE TO AS GOVERNMENT
TO GET INVOLVED WITH. SO THAT'S
ONE ARE TO BE TREATED WITH THE
RESPECT AND THE DIGNITY OF ALL
EIGHT EACH INDIVIDUAL HUMAN
BEING. THERE'S ALSO A SECOND
WHICH IS PUBLIC SAFETY AND THAT
IS ALSO VERY MUCH WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF GOVERNMENT SO I GUESS
I'D LIKE TO ASK. BECAUSE I TO
LIKE OTHERS DON'T KNOW THE
DETAILS BUT IF THERE'S A SHORT
ANSWER TO. THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
ASPECT A WHICH IS AGAIN VERY
MUCH WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
GOVERNMENT IF ANY ONE OF THE
PROPONENTS COULD. NOT TALK
ABOUT THAT. I MEAN I THINK ONE
OF THE RATIONALES FOR THE BILL
THAT WAS BROUGHT IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE AS WELL AS
WHAT'S BEHIND THE RESOLUTION IS
THE FACT THAT THESE. PRACTICES
HAVE BEEN FOUND BY ALL OF THE
MEDICAL ASSOCIATIONS AS BEING
HARMFUL TO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ENGAGED IN THEM THAT IT RESULTS
IN PSYCHOLOGICAL HARM HIGH
RATES OF DEPRESSION AND THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT THE MEDICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL EXPERTS HAVE
FOUND. YOU KNOW THIS RESOLUTION
IS ONE THAT I THINK CALLS ON.
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA TO THINK
ABOUT THE WAY THEY ARE
CONDUCTING THEIR ACTIVITIES AND
HAVE AN OPEN MIND AND LEARN
ABOUT PRACTICES THAT BABY
CONVERSION THERAPY OR MAY BE
LIKE A CONVERSION THERAPY AND
THINK ABOUT THE HARM THAT IT
HAS AS THEY CONDUCT THEMSELVES
IT IS A RESOLUTION. AND I THINK
THE ORIGINAL BILL AND ACTION
RELATED TO CONVERSION THERAPY
IS WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THESE HAVE
FOUND HAVE BEEN FOUND TO BE
HELPFUL I HAVE THE TWO OF THEM
FOUND TO BE HARMFUL AND
GOVERNMENT HAS. A ROLE IN
PROTECTING PEOPLE FROM HARM
JUST AS IT DOES IT CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND THOSE KINDS OF
LOS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THOSE OF THE TWO ISSUES THAT
BRING ME TO SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU ALL FOR.
YOUR WORK AND YOUR WOMAN IT
SHOULD MAKE NO YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
ASKED THE QUESTION SENATOR
MORNING YOUR NEXT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I TO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN.
PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS FOR
SHARING YOUR VIEWS. IN I JUST
WANT TO UNDERSCORE. THE
INTERPRETATION THEN I HAVE OF
THIS RESOLUTION. IN NO WAY
SEEKS TO VIOLATE. THE PRACTICE
OF RELIGION OR THE PRIVACY IN
CONSULTATION. IN COUNSELING
SESSIONS OR THE CONFIDENTIALITY
OF THOSE COUNSELING SESSIONS.
WHAT IT DOES DO IS ENCOURAGE
STRONGLY THAT CONVERSION
THERAPY NOT BE A COMPONENT OF
THAT COUNSELING BECAUSE OF WHAT
SCIENCE HAS FOUND TO BE
POTENTIALLY DAMAGING AND I
THINK WITH RESPECT TO MY
COLLEAGUES QUESTION THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERN IS THAT DAMAGE
CAN LEAD TO ATTEMPTED SUICIDE
MENTAL HEALTH. CHALLENGES AND
DISORDERS WHICH DO BECOME A
STATE OF CALIFORNIA INTEREST IF
WE'RE PAYING THE BILL FOR THOSE
TREATMENTS OM RESPONSES PUBLIC
SAFETY REACTIONS FIRST
RESPONDER REACTIONS TO PEOPLE
WHO HAVE MAYBE BEEN ENCOURAGED
TO PURSUE A PATH THAT AGAIN
SCIENCE AND MEDICINE. THE
AMERICAN PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION HAVEN'T SPECULATED
THEY HAVE FOUND AND DOCUMENTED
HARMFUL IMPACTS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS PROTECT THE
PUBLIC SAFETY WITH ABSOLUTE
RESPECT FOR RELIGIOUS FREEDOM
AND THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF
THOSE COUNSELING SESSIONS. AND
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME IN WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHORFOR ADVANCING
THIS CONVERSATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR STERN YOU
HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION. I DID
WANT TO GIVE THE OPPONENTS A
QUICK OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND TO
THE SCIENCE AND PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMENTS BECAUSE THEY DO.
BELIEVE THAT MISTER MORALES IN
HIS OPENING COMMENTS DID
MENTION SCIENCE. AS PART OF HIS
COMMENTS AND I JUST WANT TO
KNOW IF YOU HAD. AS AND LET ME
CARRY OUT CONDITION MY QUESTION
WITH THAT. I RECOGNIZE AND
ADMIT THAT THE FAITH COMMUNITY
HAS NOT ALWAYS BEEN GOOD ACTORS
IN THIS ARENA. THERE ARE
OBVIOUSLY IN IN EVERY ARENA OF
AMERICAN DEBATE THERE'S GOOD
ACTORS AND BAD ACTORS AND
PEOPLE THAT MAKE POSITIVE STEPS
AND PEOPLE WHO MAKE NEGATIVE
STEPS AND HAVE A NEGATIVE
IMPACT. ON OUR CULTURE.
ASSEMBLYMAN LOW HAS WORKED VERY
HARD ON THIS ON HIS IT
LEGISLATION ON THIS ACR I THINK.
I CAN CREDIT HIM MORE THAN
ANYBODY I KNOW OF IN CALIFORNIA
FOR BREAKING DOWN THE WALL OF
TENSION BETWEEN THE LGBT
COMMUNITY AND THE CHURCH. AND
PEOPLE OF FAITH AS I KNOW HE
HAS BUILT VERY POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH A MANY
PASTORS THAT I KNOW PERSONALLY
AND HE'S WORKED VERY HARD AND I
THINK HE'S DEMONSTRATED THE
LOVE AND COMPASSION THAT THAT
HE'S EXPRESSING HERE IN HIS ACR
BUT WE ARE DEBATING THE
LANGUAGE OF THE SEA ARE TODAY.
AND IT'S BEEN BROUGHT UP THE
SCIENCE AND THE AND THE PUBLIC
SAFETY SO I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO GIVE THE PART OF
THE OPPONENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ANSWER TO THAT IF THEY HAVE AN
ANSWER THEY DON'T THAT'S FINE
TOO. MY OPPOSITION TO THESE
SHARON MEANS THE SAME I'M
CONCERNED WITH THAT PARTICULAR
LANGUAGE IN THAT PARAGRAPH. BUT
WITH THAT'LL YOU'LL TO THE
OPPONENTS TO ANSWER TO THOSE
TWO QUESTIONS SO THE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ARE THE WHOLE ISSUE
THE CLAIM SAID SCIENCE AND
MEDICINE. INDICATE THAT THERE
IS A DUBBED OR DEMONIC SIR
DISAGREES WITH THE NOTION THAT
THE THERAPY WORKS AND YOU'D
LIKE A RESPONSE ON THAT ISSUE
THE TWO THINGS THAT THE
PROPONENTS FOR ABLE TO ANSWER
TO WAS THE SCIENCE IN THE
PUBLIC RIGHT. THE I'D LIKE TO
HAVE THE POINTS HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY GOOD. THROUGH THE
CHAIR THANK YOU. I AM A
CONSTITUTIONAL ATTORNEY WHO
PRACTICES IF YOU IS TO BRING
COURT I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON THE
SCIENCE BUT I HAVE REVIEWED
SOME OF THE SCIENCE AND READ
ARTICLES ABOUT IT. AND. IT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR TO BLAME
THE FAITH COMMUNITY. FOR THE
POOR MENTAL HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
ALL THE STIGMA AND PROBLEMS
RELATE IN SUICIDE RATES RELATED
TO LGBT ISSUES THERE'S A LOT OF
OTHER ISSUES GOING ON THERE
BESIDES FAITH PEOPLE'S STIGMA
OR OR PERCEIVED STIGMA. HOWEVER
IN MY AREA OF EXPERTISE THOUGH
IT IT IS THE PICK UP CASE WHICH
WAS REFERRED TO EARLIER I'D
LIKE TO BRIEFLY ADDRESS. AND
THAT THE PICK UP CASE WAS THE
CASE WITH THAT WENT TO THE
NINTH CIRCUIT ABOUT THE MINOR.
THE MINOR CONVERSION THERAPY
BAD IT WAS UP HELD AT THE NINTH
CIRCUIT. AND IF THE ROOF THE
ONLY REASON IT WAS UP HELD AT
THE NINTH CIRCUIT IS BECAUSE OF
THIS PROFESSIONAL SPEECH
EXCEPTION. AND IN THE COURTS
AND WILL NORMALLY WE WOULD
ALLOW YOU TO REGULATE THE
SPEECH HERE OF PSYCHOLOGISTS OR
PSYCHIATRISTS COUNSELLING
MINOR. BUT WE WERE GONNA
RECOGNIZE THIS NOVEL
PROFESSIONAL SPEECH EXCEPTION.
THE PROBLEM WITH. RELYING ON
THE PICK UP CASE WHICH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSIS DID. THAT
I READ LATE LAST NIGHT FOR
TODAY. IS THAT THE PICKUP CASE
HAS PENNED OVER RULED BY THE
CASE I CITED EARLIER WHICH
ISN'T A FLOOD VERSUS THE SERRA.
ON THE BIGGER CASE WASN'T
SPECIFICALLY OVERRULED BUT THE
WHOLE REASON FOR WHICH WHICH
WAS A PROFESSIONAL SPEECH
EXCEPTION TO THE FIRST
AMENDMENT PROTECTIONS. WAS OVER
RULED AND SO. MY GREAT CONCERN
HERE TODAY IS I'VE HEARD VERY
LITTLE CONCERNED EXCEPT FROM A
FEW OF THE SENATORS. ABOUT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND ABOUT THE
FREE EXERCISE OF RELIGION AND
FREEDOM OF SPEECH WHAT WE SEEM
VERY. EAGER IN THE NAME OF
PUBLIC SAFETY. OR PERCEIVED
THREATS TO PUBLIC SAFETY TO
KIND OF DO AWAY WITH THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. IF WE DO AWAY WITH
THE FIRST AMENDMENT FOLKS ALL
OF OUR FREEDOMS GO OUT THE
DOOR. AND SO WE'VE GOT TO BE
VERY CAREFUL WHEN WE USE PUBLIC
SAFETY. ARGUMENTS AND SMASHED
THE FIRST AMENDMENT CALIFORNIA
WAS BROUGHT UP SHORT INITIAL
VERSES Và SERRA. AND THEY HAD
TO PAY OVER A MILLION DOLLARS
IN ATTORNEY'S FEES I WAS CO
COUNSEL AT THE US SUPREME COURT
AND IF A PERSON TO SERRA. AND
THE IN THE LETTER I SUBMITTED
TO THIS COMMITTEE. THE COURT
VERY CLEARLY SAID IT IS IN A
CONCURRING OPINION BY JUSTICE
KENNEDY YOU JUST RETIRED HE
SAID IT IS NOT FORWARD THINKING
TO FORCE INDIVIDUALS TO BE AN
INSTRUMENT FOR FOSTERING PUBLIC
ADHERENCE WHO'D IDEOLOGICAL
POINT OF VIEW THEY FIND
UNACCEPTABLE. ITIS FORWARD
THINKING TO BEGIN BY READING
THE FIRST AMENDMENT IS RATIFIED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. TO AND
SORRY SEVENTEEN NINETY ONE TO
UNDERSTAND THE HISTORY OF
AUTHORITARIAN GOVERNMENT AS THE
FOUNDERS THEN NEW IT TO CONFIRM
THE HISTORY SINCE THEN SHOWS
HOW RELENTLESS AUTHORITARIAN
REGIMES ARE. IN THEIR ATTEMPTS
TO STIFLE FREE SPEECH IN THE
KERRY THOSE LESSONS ON WORD AS
WE SEEK TO PRESERVE AND TEACH
THE NECESSITY OF FREEDOM OF
SPEECH. FOR THE GENERATIONS TO
COME A CONCLUDE WITH THIS
GOVERNMENTS MUST NOT BE ALLOWED
TO FORCE PERSONS TO EXPRESS A
MESSAGE CONTRARY TO THEIR
DEEPEST CONVICTIONS. FREEDOM OF
SPEECH SECURE IS THE FREEDOM OF
THOUGHT AND BELIEF THIS LAW AND
PERILS THOSE LIBERTIES ACR
NINETY NINE IN PERILS THOSE
LIBERTIES SO DO NOT PLEASE DO
NOT TAKE THE FIRST AMENDMENT
LIGHTLY. THANK YOU AND I WOULD
JUST SIMPLY ADD THIS COMMITTEE
DOESN'T TAKE THE FIRST MEMBER
LIGHTLY WE'VE HEARD FROM A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT GROUPS
THOSE INCLUDING WHO WANT TO
SPEAK AT BERKELEY AND HAVE
RAISED QUESTIONS ABOUT. THE
PROTECTIONS TO THE OTHER PEOPLE
THAT THAT HAVE HAD SOMEWHAT
INCENDIARY SPEECH IN THIS
COMMITTEE HAS CONFIRM THEIR
RIGHT TO HAVE THAT SPEECH SO
THAT IS A POINT THAT I THINK IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO I THINK WE
ALL HOLD DEAR. I THINK WE
DISAGREE WITH YOU ONE WHETHER
THIS IS AN ATTACK ON THE FIRST
AMENDMENT OR WHETHER RICHEST
SIMPLY URGES THROUGH THE
SCIENCE WHICH- APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION AND THE ISSUE OF. A
SCIENCE AND MEDICINE ABOUT THE
VALIDITY OF THIS TYPE OF
COULDN'T CONVERSION THERAPY
AGAIN IS THE CENTER ON BURKE
MENTIONED IT TALKS ABOUT COMING
FROM A PLACE OF LOVE WHICH I
BELIEVE IS WHAT THE CHURCH
ESPOUSES. IT DOESN'T MANDATE
THAT YOU DO ANY PARTICULAR
THING IT IS I THINK MORE IN THE
SPIRIT AND ASKING THAT YOU
CONSIDER THAT. AS YOU GO
FORWARD TO CONSIDER THE SCIENCE
AND WHAT HAVE. AS A
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW EXPERT I
THNK YOU'LL HAVE TO AGREE THAT
THE DEFINITIONS OF FIRST
AMENDMENT VIS A VIS RELIGION.
HAVE BEEN SORT OF TURNING ON
THEIR HEAD A LITTLE BIT OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS SO IT
REMAINS TO BE SEEN HOW THIS IS
INTERPRETED GOING FOR THE FIRST
AMENDMENT ENDS VIS A VIS
RELIGION IS BEING INTERPRETED
GOING FORWARD. BUT AGAIN THE
FIRST MAMMAL LIKE ALL
AMENDMENTS IS NOT. ABSOLUTE AND
I DON'T THINK THOUGH THAT EVEN
IN THIS CASE WE ARE WE ARE AT A
POINT OF MANDATING WHAT YOU CAN
AND CANNOT DO WHAT YOU. CAN AND
CANNOT THINK BUT IT DOES A TALK
ABOUT THE SCIENCE IT DOES TALK
ABOUT IMPACTS. ENDED ASK THAT
YOU COME FROM A PLACE OF AND-
SO I DIE I APPRECIATE IS A
FIRST AMENDMENT LAWYER. BUT I
DON'T THINK THERE THAT WE
HAVEN'T GOTTEN TO THAT POINT
WHERE WE REALLY ARE IMPOSING IN
ANYWAY ON THE FIRST AMENDMENT
SO WANT TO BE THAT TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR AS THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE. AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO
RESPOND BRIEFLY PLEASE FEEL
FREE. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
THREE JONES FOR THAT QUESTION
WITH RESPECT TO THE CONVERSION
THERAPY IN PREPARATION FOR THIS
NOT BEING VERY FAMILIAR WITH IT
MYSELF. I TALKED TO A-
COLLEAGUE OF MINE WHO IS. AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN FEMALE WHO IS
A BOARD CERTIFIED MEDICAL
PHYSICIAN. AND A FORMER
PRACTICING LESBIAN. TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND CONVERSION THERAPY.
AND SO. I DO NOT STAND HERE
CITY ARRESTED REPRESENTATIVE.
ADVOCATING FOR ANYTHING THAT
WOULD DEVALUE. DE HUMANIZED
ANYONE OR WOULD MAKE THEM FEEL
LESS THAN THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE
ABOUT THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M ABOUT
JESUS ABOUT LOVE AND SO. ANY
KIND OF THERAPY. THAT WOULD
SEEK TO SAY YOU'RE A BAD PERSON
YOU ARE WRONG PERSON OR AGAIN
DE VALUE YOU IS THAT WHAT WE'RE
ADVOCATING FOR BUT WE ARE
ADVOCATING OR WHAT WE ARE
PROPOSING IS THE LANGUAGE WHICH
WAS SO ELOQUENTLY CALLED OUT
THAT WOULD PROHIBIT MY ABILITY
AS A PASTOR MY COLLEAGUES
ABILITY AS A PASTOR RELATIVE TO
MEDICAL SCIENCE. FROM SOMEONE'S
OPPORTUNITY AND FREEDOM TO SAY.
IF I WANT TO SEEK THERAPEUTIC
COUNSELING THAT IF THEY LEGAL
THAT VALUES ME AS AN
INDIVIDUAL. IF I WANT TO SPEAK
TRANSFORMATIVE COUNSELING
THROUGH A CHRISTIAN COUNSELOR
THAT I SHOULD HAVE THE FREEDOM
TO DO SO MY THING WOULD BE LIST
JUST TAKE THAT ONE SECTION OUT
OF A R. C. NINETY NINE AND I
THINK WE'LL BE ALL SET. THANK
YOU I DO THINK THOUGH. NOTHING
IS PROHIBITED IN THIS.
RESOLUTION IT. IT'S SIMPLY AN
ENCOURAGEMENT. A STATEMENT TO
COUNSEL WITH LOVE IN A
KNOWLEDGE OF THE OVERWHELMING
SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS WHICH I
DON'T THINK HAS BEEN REFUTED
HERE I DON'T THINK THERE'S BEEN
ANY EXPERTS COMING IN TO SAY
THIS THE SCIENCE IS NOT REAL.
DATA AGAIN SIMPLY ASKED FOR A
COMING FROM A PLACE OF LOVE IN
KNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS OF
CONCERN SO OF DON'T THINK IT
IMPEDES ON THE FIRST AMENDMENT
YOU KNOW MAYBE WRONG MAYBE
THEY'LL GIVE YOU SOME MORE
BUSINESS TO KEEP YOU BUSY BUT I
THINK AT THIS POINT IN TIME
LIST FOR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS WE
HAVE A MOTION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW WOULD YOU LIKE DID YOU WANT
TO SPEAK CENTER STERN.NO OKAY
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES FOR THE OPTION TO
SPEAK ON THIS JUST FOR CONTEXT
BECAUSE IT TEARS THAT NUMBER OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRESS ONE
HERE IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE FORTY
THREE. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE THE STATE MADE A STRONG
STATEMENT THAT WE SAID YES
THERE'S A HARMFUL PRACTICE OF
CONVERSION THEIR FREE FOR
MINORS EIGHTEEN AND UNDER THAT
IS THE LAW OF THE LAND THAT HAS
BEEN UP HEALTH. MULTIPLE TIMES
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE WHICH
BY THE WAY FIFTEEN OTHER STATES
HAVE ALSO SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND TWELVE ALSO PASSED SIMILAR
TYPES OF LEGISLATION
RECOGNIZING THE SIGNS. OF ALL
OF THESE OTHER SO STATIONS.
LAST YEAR THEN WE SAID WELL WE
WANT TO PROTECT ALL PEOPLE NOT
JUST MINORS AND THAT'S WHY WE
NEARLY. FOCUSING TAILORED
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE FORTY
THREE LAST YEAR. ON CONVERSION
THERAPY AS A FRAUDULENT
PRACTICE WHICH IS THAT IF
THERE'S A FINANCIAL
TRANSACTION. THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED A FRAUDULENT
PRACTICE BUT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE TESTIFIED HERE TODAY
IN OPPOSITION WOULD STILL BE A
LATE ABLE. TO PRACTICE THE
CONVERSION THERAPY SHOULD THEY-
SHOULD THEY WISH TO DO SO. SO
LONG AS AN THERE'S NOT THAT
FINANCIAL TRANSACTION. THAT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION PASSED
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE. BUT IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WE ALSO HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH.
EVANGELICAL LEADERS BECAUSE I
THOUGHT IS VERY IMPORTANT. TO
ENCOURAGE THAT TYPE OF. A
STRONGER APPROACH IN
INCORPORATING MADE A DIFFERENT
VALUES OF ALL PEOPLE. YOU CAN
AMASS AN- MIKE SAID THE ANGST
OF OUR SPONSORS AND FRANKLY OF.
THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA WE
PAUSED IN I HELD THAT BILL. IT
WAS READY TO GO TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK FOR SENATOR BE
HELD THAT BILL SAID WHY. THE
CALL CALIFORNIA SAID WHAT ARE
YOU DOING. I SAID I WANT TO
PAUSE BECAUSE I THINK WE CAN DO
THIS TOGETHER I THINK WE CAN BE
TRANSFORMATIVE IN THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE AS A
RESULT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE FORTY THREE OF A
FRAUDULENT PRACTICE CONVERSION
THERAPY AS A FRONT IN PRACTICE.
I NEVER OF FAITH LEADERS SAID
WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH YOU
BUT WE THINK THIS GOES JUST A
LITTLE BIT TOO FAR TO COULD WE
WORK TOGETHER WITH YOU AND
COMING UP WITH SOME LANGUAGE.
SO WHAT YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU
TODAY. IN CAPS LATE THE WORK.
PARTNERSHIP COUNTER TO WHAT YOU
HEARD FROM TESTIMONY IS
ACTUALLY CONTRARY TO THAT IN
FACT THIS WAS DONE IN
COLLABORATION WITH FAITH
LEADERS THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
STATE TO WHICH I KNOW SENATOR
JONES KNOWS I HAVE TRAVELED
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE TO
MEET WITH EVANGELICAL LEADERS
TO GET THEIR SUPPORT ON THIS
PIECE OF RESOLUTION INCLUDE
INCLUDING KEVIN MANILA THE
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
EVANGELICALS SO AGAIN WOULD YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU HERE. IS THE
WORK OF A COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH WITH MEMBERS OF THE
FAITH COMMUNITY THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE STATE TO SAY WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH YOU AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN BUILD OFF OF
THIS WORKING RELATIONSHIP TO
IDENTIFY HOW WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER COLLABORATIVELY MOVING
FORWARD FROM A PLACE OF LOVE
COMPASSION AND RECOGNIZING ALL
PEOPLE LET ME JUST FINALLY JUST
SAY THAT THAT. THIS IS A NON
BINDING RESOLUTION. THIS IS A
NON BINDING RESOLUTION. SO THE
OPPOSITION WAS OPPOSE LAST TIME.
IN WHICH THEY WERE NOT
NECESSARILY AT THE TABLE AND IT
WAS NEARLY SCOPE TO FINANCIAL
TRANSACTION UNDER THE CONSUMER
LEGAL REMEDIES ACT VERY NARROW
IN SCOPE. AND YET EVEN WITH
EVANGELICAL LEADERS THEY'RE
STILL OPPOSED SOME SOME ARE
STILL OPPOSE. SO IT'S JUST VERY
CLEAR TO ME THAT THERE WILL BE
A CONVERSATION OF A DIFFERENCE
OF THIS I'M SURE THE OPPOSITION
WOULD STILL BE OPPOSED AMERICA
QUALITY OR MY OPPORTUNITY TO
ADOPT OR TO DONATE BLOOD TO BE
PART OF THE BOY SCOUTS ARE TO
SERVE A MILITARY. WE'VE ALREADY
SETTLED THIS. BUT AGAIN WHAT
YOU SEE HERE BEFORE YOU IS A
COLLABORATION OF THE WORK THAT
I THINK I AM HOPEFUL THAT WE
CAN BE. WE CAN STAND ON THIS IN
A TRANSFORMATIVE WAY TO SAY
THAT WE STAND TOGETHER AND
UNITED IN THESE EFFORTS AND
BUILD OFF OF THIS AS WELL BUT
AGAIN THIS NOTION OF CONVERSION
THERAPY IS THE ANTI FEDERAL TO
MY VERY EXISTENCE THIS NOTION.
THAT ONE COULD BE CHANGED. IS
DAMAGING TO ALL PEOPLE THAT
SOMEHOW WE SHOULD BE CHANGED OR
IF WE SHOULD SEEK THIS OUT
RATHER WE SHOULD BE ACCEPTED.
AND SO THIS STATEMENT OF
AFFIRMATION IS OF LOVE AND
COMPASSION AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL LEAH MOTION IS.
THE MET ITEM BE IT ADOPTED AS
AMENDED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE BORDERS
OR JUST NO DO RUSSELL RUSSELL I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES JONES
NO MONNING MONEY AYE STERN
STERN I BURKE. NUMBER OF IOWA
CASKEY RECALLS K<c.cyan></c><c.cyan>WI ALL</c>
RIGHT SEVEN TO TWO THAT MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU ALL APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY. AND WE'LL TAKE
A MOMENT SO THAT THOSE WHO
DON'T WISH TO STAY FOR LAST
ITEM CAN FEEL FREE TO LEAVE OF
WILL GIVE A MOMENT BEFORE WE
START THE NEXT MEASURE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BYE BYE. YES.
VERY NICE REPRESENTING
. SO YOU
.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE NEED TO GO
FIRST BUT- IT IS NOT OURS TO
ASK WHY. GOOD HOW ARE YOU FINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA I HOPE THIS. NEXT ITEM
ISN'T QUITE AS CONTROVERSIAL
BUT YOU NEVER KNOW SO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PROCEED AGAIN TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH AND
SUPPORT TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH IN OPPOSITION.
LARA SHORES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANT TO
START BY THANKING YOUR
COMMITTEE SENATOR FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. HR NINETEEN CALLS
UPON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
RESET ALL THE THIRTY THOUSAND
REFUGEES OF THE UNITED STATES
HAVE COMMITTED TO RESETTLE IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN. AS
YOU ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA'S LONG
BEEN A WELCOMING HOME FOR
REFUGEES RESETTLED INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT IS A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT THE REQUIRES ALL LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS TO
WORK TOGETHER. SO IT'S OF
UTMOST IMPORTANCE THAT EVERYONE
COMES TOGETHER IN UNITED FRONT
TO RESETTLE REFUGEES HOWEVER
UNFORTUNATELY THAT HAS NOT BEEN
THE CASE IN RECENT YEARS
CERTAINLY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION HAS
DRASTICALLY CUT THE INCLINATION
OF NET REFUGEE ARRIVALS AND
EFFECTIVELY ELIMINATED ALMOST
HALF OF THE REFUGEE RESELLERS
SPOTS. AVAILABLE IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD. IT'S IS WELCOME FEWER
THAN ELEVEN THOUSAND REFUGEES
SO FAR. WE ARE MORE THAN
HALFWAY THROUGH THE YEAR. AT
THIS RATE THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL COME NOWHERE NEAR
RESETTLING ITS GOAL OF THIRTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS. A GOAL%
WHICH PALES IN COMPARISON TO
THE HISTORIC AVERAGE COMMITMENT
OF NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
REFUGEES ANNUALLY. CONGRESS AND
OF BEEN THE PRESIDENT HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO CONTINUE TO STAND
BEHIND THIS INCREDIBLY VALUABLE
POPULATION. AS WE HAVE DONE FOR
SO MANY YEARS IN THE PAST WITH
ME TODAY ARE CATCHING WITH A
COMMUNITY ADVOCACY RAP FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL RESCUE COMMITTEE.
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS DATA BOSTON BOSTON AS A QUé
ALL CLOSE. I DID I GET IT YEAH
AND I DIDN'T IS AGAIN THE
ASSEMBLY SUCH A REFUGEE VOICE
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL RESCUE
COMMITTEE. I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
THE MANAGER. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
HERE ARE ON THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION BE A PART OF IT
TODAY. MY NAME IS KATE CHIANG
AND I'M AN ADVOCATE WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL RESCUE COMMITTEE.
AT THE I RC IS A REFUGEE. AID
AND RESETTLEMENT AGENCY THAT
OPERATES INTERNATIONALLY. HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE SEVEN DIFFERENT OFFICES
AND WE'VE WORKED HERE PROVIDING
RESETTLEMENT SERVICES FOR
ALMOST FORTY YEARS. OUR WORK
INVOLVES PROVIDING THE
NECESSARY SERVICES TO ENSURE AN
EFFECTIVE AND PRODUCTIVE
RESETTLEMENT FOR NEWLY ARRIVED
REFUGEES INCLUDES THINGS LIKE.
CULTURAL ORIENTATION HOUSING
JOB PLACEMENT INCLUDE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE EDUCATION AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES NOT TO MENTION
GETTING KIDS ENROLLED IN SCHOOL
GETTING FOLKS SET UP WITH
HEALTHCARE. I'M AND JOB
TRAINING IN ADDITION TO BASIC
PLACEMENT. OVER THE DECADES
THAT WE HAVE WORKED HERE WE
HAVE WATCH THOUSANDS OF
CLIENTS. REBUILD THEIR LIVES
WITH IMPRESSIVE RESILIENCE TO
BECOME INVESTED AN INTEGRAL
MEMBERS OF THEIR NEW
COMMUNITIES. BUT OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS THE NUMBERS OF
REFUGEE ARRIVALS HAVE BEEN
SLASHED AND THAT HAS CAUSED
ACUTE PAIN. INCLUDING THE
CLOSURE OF OFFICES ACROSS THE
STATE WHICH PROVIDE CONTINUING
SERVICES TO FOLKS FOR UP TO
FIVE YEARS AFTER THEY ARRIVE.
BUT THESE LOW ARRIVALS ARE NOT
DUE TO A LACK OF NEED ON THE
CONTRARY THE NEED FOR STATE
THIRD PARTY RESETTLEMENT IN THE
GLOBE HAS NEVER BEEN HIGHER.
AND THIS LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY POWERFUL ALLY
PASSING KEY LEGISLATION OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA REMAINS A FOR
FIND LOCATION FOR REFUGEES TO
COME TO OBTAIN EMPLOYMENT AND
TO INTEGRATE SUCCESSFULLY. AS
WE APPROACH THE FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY WE AWAIT NEWS OF
WITH HEWLETT ADMISSIONS LEVELS
WILL BE THIS YEAR FROM THE
PRESIDENT. BUT WE HAVE HEARD
AND SEEN REPORTS THAT THE
PROGRAM COULD BE COMPLETELY
DISMANTLED. THAT WOULD BE AS
ASSEMBLYMAN GLORIA SAID A SIEVE
SIGNIFICANT DEVIATION FROM
HISTORICAL AVERAGE NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND REFUGEES THE UNITED
STATES HAS RESETTLED ANNUALLY
SINCE THE PROGRAM BEGAN IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY. AND I KEY
HISTORICAL MARKER WHICH HAS
ENJOYED BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR THAT ENTIRE PERIOD
OF TIME. SO RESOLUTIONS LIKE AJ
ARE NINETEEN ARE MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER TO EXHIBIT STRONG
SUPPORT FOR REFUGEES AND
REFLECT THE VALUES AND THE
PRIORITIES OF OUR GREAT STATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
TWO MINUTES PLEASE OUR HELLO MY
NAME IS THE NUMBER STAND SICK
AND I'M THE REFUGEE VOICE WITH
THE INTERNATIONAL RESCUE
COMMITTEE HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AND I'M REALLY HONORED TO BE
HERE IN THIS PLACE OF DEMOCRACY
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF H.
A R. NINETEEN WHICH DOES NOT ON
THE EXTEND SUPPORT AND WELCOME
TO THE REFUGEES BEING VERSATILE
AND CALIFORNIA. BUT ALSO CALLS
UPON THE ADMINISTRATION TO
INCREASE THE NUMBERS OFF THE
ADMISSIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY MUCH MUCH HIGHER
THAN THAT NOW. I HAVE A FEELING
WE HAVE TO BE CONSTANTLY
REMINDED THAT REFUGEES TO NOT
ARE NOT ACTUALLY LEAVING THEIR
PLACES BY CHOICE. REFUGEES ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE FLEEING
PERSECUTION AND WAR. ALTHOUGH
IT HAS BEEN MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS SINCE I HAVE BEEN
RECYCLED FROM BOSNIA AND
HERZEGOVINA AS A REFUGEE. I
STILL VIVIDLY CARRY. WITH ME
THE MEMORIES OF THE DAY WHEN I
WAS FORCED TO LEAVE. THAT WAS
THE DAY WHEN WOMEN AND YOUNG
GIRLS WERE TAKEN TO THE
CONCENTRATION CAMP A PLACE OF
TORTURE AND DEATH. I WAS REALLY
I'M SO HAPPY THAT I WAS THE
LUCKY ONE OR ONE OF THE LUCKY
ONES TO ESCAPE AND I WAS ABLE
TO BE RESETTLED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I FOUND MY NEW HOME
HERE AND CALIFORNIA. AND I
STARTED MY LIFE A NEW AGAIN AND
FROM THE VERY FIRST MOMENT I
HAVE FELT ACCEPTED. I HAVE
STARTED WORKING IMMEDIATELY
I'VE NEVER BEEN BURDEN TO THIS
SOCIETY I'VE STARTED WORKING
FOR THE INTERNATIONAL RESCUE
COMMITTEE HELPING OTHER
REFUGEES START THEIR NEW LIFE
AND FREEDOM. AND BASICALLY I'M
SO HAPPY THAT CALIFORNIA IS
STILL FOLLOWING THE HISTORICAL
ROLE OF BEING THE LEADER OF THE
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT AND BEING
THE WELCOMING PLACE AND I THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TODAY
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF. AJ ARE
NINETEEN AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THERE ARE SOME OF US
HERE REMEMBER THE BOSNIA
HERZEGOVINA. CHALLENGES THAT I
THINK ARE STILL GOING ON. SO
THANK YOU WELCOME. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DYESS. SENATOR BORCHERS. THANK
YOU ARE BIGGER BRING THIS ITEM
FORD I JUST HAVE A QUESTION
WE'RE REFERRING TO THESE
INDIVIDUALS AS AS REFUGEES BUT
LIKE FROM A LEGAL CONTEXT ARE
THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE NOT YET
BEEN. PROCESSED IN BEEN GRANTED
ASYLUM. OKAY SO M. THE WAY THAT
THE PROCESSING AND RESETTLEMENT
SYSTEM WORKS IS THAT THERE ARE
ROUGHLY TWENTY SIX MILLION
REFUGEES IN THE WORLD TODAY AND
THAT'S A SPECIFIC INTERNATIONAL
LEGAL DEFINITION SOMEBODY WHO
HAS BEEN. FORCED TO FLEE ACROSS
AN INTERNATIONAL BORDER DUE TO
FEAR OF PERSECUTION OR DEATH
BECAUSE OF MEMBERSHIP IN ONE OF
FIVE PROTECTED CLASS YOU'RE
STRAIGHT. I'M HEY ACROSS THE
INTERNATIONAL BORDER REFUGEES
CAN APPLY THROUGH THE UNITED
NATIONS THE UNHCR FOR
RESETTLEMENT. I'M IT IS
SOMETHING THAT GENERALLY LESS
THAN 1% OF THE REFUGEE
POPULATION EVER HAS ACCESS TO.
AND THE UNITED STATES HAS
AGREED TO BE ONE OF ROUGHLY
TWENTY COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD
WHO HAS AGREED TO VOLUNTARILY
ACCEPT. AND RESETTLE THOSE
REFUGEES WHO APPLY FOR
RESETTLEMENT GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND ARE SELECTED OKAY
BUT GOING THROUGH THE U. N.
RIGHT. SO THIS IS NOT. AS A
SCENARIO WHERE WE'VE EXPERIENCE
ON THE NORTHERN OR SOUTHERN
SIDE. YEAH THIS WAS THIS IS AN
INTERNATIONAL REPLACEMENT
PROGRAM PLACEMENT PROGRAM. IF
THAT'S CORRECT. OKAY SO THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT GET RESETTLED.
BALLOTS FOR USE THE US FOR
EXAMPLE. WE HAVE ACCEPTED THEM
AS REFUGEES OR WE HAVE ACCEPTED
THEM. AND GIVEN THEM ASYLUM
STATUS. RIGHT TO THE WAY THAT
IT WORKS IS THE REFUGEES APPLY
THROUGH THE UNITED NATIONS AND
THE UNITED STATES WORKS WITH
THE U. NH C. R. AND THEY'RE
ROUGHLY NINE FEDERAL AGENCIES.
PART OF HOMELAND SECURITY STATE
DEPARTMENT AMONG OTHERS THAT
WORK TO VET THOSE FOLKS WHO
HAVE APPLIED IT ROUGHLY TAKES
ABOUT THREE YEARS. FOR THE
RESETTLEMENT DECISION TO BE
MADE. THEN THEY ARE ACCEPTED IN
EVERY YEAR THE PRESIDENT SETS A
C. ON HER YEAH RIGHT OF HOW
MANY. OF THOSE FOLKS WE WILL
ACCEPT TO RESETTLE HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES HISTORICALLY AS
THE SOMEONE SAID IT'S BEEN
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY ROUGHLY. LAST
YEAR WAS DROPPED TO FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND IN THIS. YEAR WAS SET
FOR THIRTY THOUSAND. AND THOSE
FOLKS WHO ARE ACCEPTED THROUGH
THE DIFFERENT FEDERAL AGENCIES
AND ONCE THE AGREEMENT IS MADE.
THEY ARE THEN ASSIGNED TO ONE
OF THE NINE RESETTLEMENT
AGENCIES THAT WORK IN THE
UNITED STATES SO THE
INTERNATIONAL RESCUE COMMITTEE
IS ONE OF THOSE NINE
RESETTLEMENT AGENCIES. WE GET
WORD THAT THEY ARE COMING AND
WE WORK WITH THEM WITH CASE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS TO
ESTABLISH HOUSING JOB PLEASE.
YES WHAT IS THEIR STATUS UPON
ENTRY INTO THEIR STATUS IS THAT
OF A REFUGEE. THROUGH THE
INTERNATIONAL OFFICE OF
MIGRATION BUT HAVE THEY BEEN
GRANTED ASYLUM BY THE U. S.
UPON. ENTRY INTO THE US AT NO
THEY'RE CC THEY'RE
CONSIDERED REFUGEES ASIDE THESE
YET THE DEFINITIONS DIFFERENCE
ON A SLIGHTLY. THE DEFINITION
IS ROUGHLY THE SAME IN TERMS OF
THE PROTECTED CATEGORIES OF
PEOPLE BUT A SIDE OF THESE ARE
FOLKS. WHO CROSSED INTO OUR
COUNTRY ACROSS ONE OF THE
BORDERS AND PERCENT PRESENT
THEMSELVES TO OUR BORDER
SECURITY AGENCIES. AND SAY I AM
HERE TO REQUEST ASYLUM.
REFUGEES ARE FOLKS WHO ARE
RECOGNIZED THROUGH THE UNITED
NATIONS AND GOT IT PROCESS AS A
REFUGEE THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION. I THINK THAT.
THIS IS THIS IS A PROCESS.
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF VETTING THAT GOES INTO THIS
PROCESS. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
IT IS ONE THAT IS AGREED UPON
BY THE UNITED STATES IN
PARTICIPATION WITH THIS PROGRAM
THAT THAT'S CORRECT YES. WE
HAVE A HISTORY IN THIS COUNTRY
OF WELCOMING INDIVIDUALS IN
TIMES OF NEED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WHAT QUESTIONS OTHER
QUESTIONS CENTER DRAWS SO DID
YOU HAVE A QUESTION. YOU WANT
TO MOVE THE BILL AS AMENDED.
YES ALRIGHT THE- BUT I JUST
WANNA SAY COUPLE OF THINGS I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
PARTICULAR. THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN ASYLUM AND IN REFUGEE
UP BUT IT SEEMS TO ME WHAT WE
SEEM TO KEEP CONTINUES TO GO
THROUGH GENERATION PAST
GENERATION IS TO FORGET THE
PREVIOUS GENERATIONS GROUP. OF
REFUGEES. AND IT DEPENDS ON
WHERE THEY COME FROM.
CRITICALLY THAT'S WHAT YOU KNOW
OUR GOVERNMENT USES TO DECIDE
IF THEY'RE GONNA EXCEPT THE
MORE OR NOT ACCEPT THEM SO
THERE WAS A DIFFERENT POLICY
USE WITH CUBANS AND WITH
VIETNAMESE AND WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES OF FROM. GET OUT
THEY'RE JUST DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT THIS GOVERNMENT HAS
DECIDED TO ACCEPT REFUGEES ARE
NOT ACCEPT REFUGEES CENTRAL
AMERICANS FELL THE DORIANS
BECAUSE OF THE WAR. SO YOU KNOW
MY CONCERN IS THAT AND THE
REASON I'M SUPPORTING THIS IS
BECAUSE WE SHOULD HAVE A
SYSTEM. I UNDERSTAND THAT WE
CAN TAKE TWENTY ONE MILLION OF
PEOPLE BUT WE CERTAINLY SHOULD
HAVE A SYSTEM THAT IS BASED ON
THE NEED IN THAT COUNTRY AND
THERE'S REAL HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS IT'S TAKING PLACE IN
THESE COUNTRIES AND WE SHOULD
NOT FORGET THE PAST GENERATIONS
THE HUNGARIANS THE- JEWISH THE
IRISH THERE WERE ALL THESE.
TIMES THESE ARE THE GENERATIONS
THAT HAVE THEIR GROUPS AND WE
JUST SEEM TO GO THROUGH THE
SAME THING OVER AND OVER AGAIN
WITH THE CURRENT REFUGEE SO.
YOU KNOW I SUPPORT THIS BUT
IT'S GOT TO BE PUT IN A BROADER
CONTEXT AND SORT OF THE LEGAL.
LEGAL DIFFERENCES ON AND THAT'S
WHY CALIFORNIA'S GOTTA KEEP
INSISTING THAT WE SHOULD HAVE A
FAIR REFUGEE POLICY AND NOT ONE
THAT YOU KNOW WE WITH WHEN WE
DECIDE THIS IT'S LIFE AND DEATH
FOR THE THOSE FAMILIES WITH
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND SOMEHOW
WE JUST LOSE IT LOSE THAT
PERSPECTIVE SO THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
SENATOR JONES. AFTER A QUICK
QUESTION AB TWO QUESTIONS I
THINK YOU CAN ANSWER TOGETHER.
ONE HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH
THE NUMBERS THIRTY THOUSAND AND
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND. AND TWO
ARE THOSE NATIONAL NUMBERS AND
YOU'RE WANTING ALL OF ALL THE
ALL THE REFUGEES IN AMERICA IT
ACCEPTS. THE COME TO CALIFORNIA
OR ARE YOU I'M SO TELL ME HOW
YOU GOT TO THE NUMBERS PLEASE.
SO THIRTY THOUSAND IS WHAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
COMMITTED TO BUT IS CLEARLY NOT
LIVING UP TO. SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND IS A SUBSTANTIALLY
HIGHER NUMBER THAN CLOSER TO
THE HISTORIC NORMS AND NOW
WE'RE NOT SAYING SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND FOR SO FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND FIVE THOUSAND THE
NATIONAL. ALL RIGHT OF
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I TO SHARE THE CONCERNS THAT WE
ARE A NATION OF IMMIGRANTS THE
FACT THAT WE ARE VILIFYING
IMMIGRANTS TODAY IS UNSETTLING
MOST OF THESE PEOPLE ARE COMING
FROM TROUBLED NATIONS ELSEWHERE
AROUND THE WORLD THEY'RE
DESPERATE. WE KNOW THAT MOST
PEOPLE DON'T LEAVE HOME TO GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE. JUST FOR THE
HECK OF IT THEY COME BECAUSE
THEY ARE IN FEAR OF THEIR LIVES
OR THEY BELIEVE THAT THE OF
PROMISE OF GREATER OPPORTUNITY
IT'S TRAUMATIC TO LEAVE WHAT
YOU'RE NOT WHICH TRAUMATIC I
SUSPECT TO LEAVE A COUNTRY
WHERE YOU KNOW THE LANGUAGE TO
A COUNTRY WHERE YOU DON'T. SO I
THINK THAT WE HAVE TO STOP
VILIFYING PEOPLE AND TAKE A
LOOK AT THOSE WHO ARE REALLY
COMING HERE OF FOR THEIR SAFETY
AND SECURITY IN BECAUSE- AS WE
SEE THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH FAMINE OR
DROUGHT OR- IDEOLOGICAL REASONS
OR OR THE KIND OF PROGRAMS THAT
BROUGHT MY GRANDPARENTS FROM.
EASTERN EUROPE WHERE THE
COUNTRY DID A TO SOME EXTENT
OPEN ITS BORDERS THAT TO SOME
EXTENT IT DIDN'T BUT CERTAINLY
A POLICY HUMAN A HUMANISTIC
POLICY AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THE- OBISPO QUESTION BY SENATOR
JONES WE'RE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
NATION WIDE AND WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT OPENING OUR
BORDERS TO MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE BUT TO
CONTINUE A POLICY. THAT HAS
PROVEN IN THE FACT TO BE FAIRLY
EFFECTIVE WELL I THINK WE HAVE
TO RECOGNIZED THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD WE'RE SEEING MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE DESPERATELY SEEKING
TO MIGRATE TO OTHER COUNTRIES
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS. AND
THE NEED FOR US TO RE EVALUATE
OUR POLICY AND TO RECOGNIZE
THAT WE ARE BUILT ON THE
NATION'S IMMIGRATION WHETHER IT
WAS THE POTATO FARMERS. IN
IRELAND TO WHICH REFLECTS SOME
OF US HERE. I KNOW MY
GRANDFATHER CAME OVER IN A OF A
OF FLOOD OF IMMIGRATION
INCLUDING GREEKS. SOME OF HIS
BEST FRIENDS WERE YOUNG FOLKS
FROM FROM GREECE THAT HAD
ESCAPED WHATEVER. THE ECONOMIC
TRAVAILS WERE EXISTING THEN TO
HIS DYING DAYS HE INSISTED UPON
DANCING GREEK DANCES FOR SHE
WAS NOT VERY GOOD AT IT BUT-
BUT CHIPS YOU KNOW AGAIN TO
EMBRACE. ALL OF THE WONDERFUL
CULTURE SO WE BRING TO THIS
COUNTRY SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALSO FOR BRINGING THIS AND WE
DO HAVE PROMOTION AS AMENDED IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE SPREADING
CATON DINA FOR THEIR TEST FIND
SUPPORT WANT TO NOTE FOR THE
RECORD THAT EVERY LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS HAS ENDORSED THIS
RESOLUTION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOU I VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED B.
EXCUSE ME THAT A BE ADOPTED AS
AMENDED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
JACKSON AYE JACKSON AYE PORCHES
OR DECIDE TO RUSSELL. RUSSELL.
I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I'D JONES.
MONNING AYE MONNING ICE STERN
STERN I BURKE. NUMBER I WOULD
HOUSE HE I KELSEY I EIGHT ZERO
EIGHT TWO. EIGHT TWO ZERO THAT
THE MEASURES OUT LET'S CALL THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ONE MORE TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE SO MUCH AS THEM. ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE ONE OTHER ITEM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS STERN. STERN
AYE WHY CASKEY BECAUSE THE AYE
ALL RIGHT. EIGHT ZERO NINE TWO
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT AND WE
ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU ALL